VRAYLAR helps smooth the ups
and downs.
BRIAN: THE NEW ADMINISTRATION’S
DECISION TO STOP BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION HAS FORCED CREWS TO
PUT DOWN TOOLS.
THIS KILLS ME, AND WALK AWAY IN
THE MIDDLE OF WORK.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS A WALL WE
ALREADY PAID FOR.
A DECISION THAT ONE ARIZONA
SHERIFF SAID LEFT BEHIND A
ROADWAY FOR SMUGGLERS.
SHERIFF MARK DANIELS IS IN
CHARGE OF COCHIEF COUNTY, HE
JOINS US NOW.
WE PAID FOR THE WALL TO BE BUILT
ALONG WITH THE TECHNOLOGY AND
ALONG WITH THE ROADS.
NOW WE ARE PAYING TO MOVE THE
WALL, STORE THE WALL OR DESTROY
THE WALL AND GUESS WHAT, THE
ILLEGALS ACCORDING TO WHAT
YOU’RE TELLING US ARE USING IT
TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY.
IN WHAT WAY?
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING, BRIAN.
IT’S A PRODUCT OF POLITICS
WITHIN POLICING.
AND I’VE ALWAYS SAID.
THEY HAVE NO BUSINESS IN OUR --
IN THE BUSINESS OF POLICING AND
WHAT WE DO ON THIS BORDER AND
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN RESCINDED
THE EMERGENCY ORDER ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER, IT STOPPED
RESOURCES AND STOPPED
CONSTRUCTION ON OUR BORDER.
AS A RESULT OF THAT, ONE AREA
WHERE THE FENCE IS NOT COMPLETE,
WE GET 5 OR 6 GROUPS A DAY
COMING ACROSS THERE.
IT’S OPEN UP THE BORDER AND
OPENED UP TO COME INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THIS ADMINISTRATION OWNS THIS
DECISION AND WAS DOING THIS AND
FORCING BACK TO 2019 WHERE I HAD
THE LARGEST CRIME SCENE IN THE
COUNTRY TO INCLUDE THE LARGEST
HUMANITARIAN SITUATION GOING ON.
BRIAN: SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
STILL THAT IS YOU GUYS SENT US.
>> THESE PICTURES COME OFF OUR
-- WE HAVE OUR OWN CAMERA SYSTEM
WITH CBP.
THESE PICTURES I’M SHOWING YOU
CAME OFF OUR CAMERA SYSTEM WHERE
YOU SEE THE SMUGGLING COMING
THROUGH OUR DESERTS.
IT’S WIDE OPEN RIGHT NOW.
IT’S WIDE OPEN AND WITH THE
CHAOS GOING ON IN THE BORDER
BASED ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISIONS AND WE SAW THIS IN
2019, BRIAN, 141 COUNTRIES
BREACHED OUR BORDER, OVER A
THOUSAND GANG MEMBERS, 822
ASSAULTS ON AGENTS.
271 DEATHS ON OUR BORDER.
THIS IS A CRIME SCENE AND THIS
IS WHAT WE JUST PUT TOGETHER.
WE HAD IT UNDER CONTROL.
THIS IS FRUSTRATING AND NOW T
GOING BACK TO 2019.
IT’S FRUSTRATING.
BRIAN: I MEAN, I DON’T WANT TO
GET YOU INTO POLITICS, WE JUST
FIRED 15,000 PEOPLE WORKING ON A
PIPELINE THAT HAD ZERO IMPACT ON
THE ENVIRONMENT AND WENT TO THE
BORDER AND BLEW IT UP FOR PURE
POLITICAL PURPOSES AND MADE YOUR
LIFE MISERABLE AND PUT OUR
COUNTRY IN GREATER DANGER.
KEEP IN MIND SOME OF THE NUMBERS
AND THE NUMBERS DON’T DIE,
BORDER ENCOUNTERS IN THE FISCAL
YEAR 2020-2021.
73,000 IN DECEMBER AND 73,000 IN
JANUARY.
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, THEY
SAID IT WAS A CRISIS, HE CALLED
IT A TRAGEDY.
THAT WAS 188 PER DAY.
TODAY WE ARE PROJECTED TO HAVE A
117,000 THIS YEAR.
WHAT’S HE GOING THE CALL IT
THEN?
WHAT CHANGED?
>> WELL, POLITICS CHANGE.
POLITICS CHANGE.
IDEOLOGIES CHANGE.
IT’S HYPOCRITICAL TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU, BRIAN.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST
AND WHERE WE ARE AT TODAY IT’S
HYPOCRITICAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
GOES AGAINST GRAIN OF THE DCD.
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR DR. FAUCI
WHICH NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER, THEY ARE
NOT TESTING THEM, THEY ARE BEING
RELEASED WITHOUT BEING TESTED IN
THE COMMUNITIES AND YOU LOOK AT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ASPECT OF
THIS.
IT’S UPSETTING.
IT’S ALMOST LIKE WE ARE NOT PART
OF THE COUNTRY WHICH IS VERY
UPSETTING.
BRIAN: WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
SOMEONE ASKED YOU IF YOU WERE
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
ONE IS RIGHT AND ONE IS WRONG.
YOU SAID REMAIN THE MEXICO
POLICY WHICH HAS BEEN BLOWN UP,
YOU SAID NEW PROPOSAL BY THE
MEXICAN LEADER CAN BRING 600,
700,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS A
YEAR?
>> JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE,
BRIAN, IN OUR CAMERA SYSTEM, 700
AT A TIME, A YEAR AGO TODAY WE
WERE RUNNING IN OUR CAMERA
SYSTEM 300 TO 400 A MONTH.
IN AUGUST WHEN THE POLICIES
KICKED UP WE JUMP TODAY 1200 A
MONTH.
IN DECEMBER IT WAS OVER 2500
ENTRIES TO ILLEGAL ENTRIES LET
ME SAY TO INCLUDE OVER
501 POUNDS OF ELICIT DRUGS.
IT’S SKYROCKETING, BACK THE TO
THE NUMBERS WE SAW IN 2019.
THE REASON WE HAVE MPP AND
OTHERS PRESIDENT TRUMP IN PLACE
BECAUSE OF CARAVAN SURGES.
IT WORKED.
IT’S NOT WORKING NOW.
BRIAN: YEAH.
SHERIFF, I FEEL BAD FOR HOW YOUR
LIFE CHANGED BECAUSE OF PURE
POLITICS, SHERIFF MARK DANNELS,